wer würde er die mutter bekommt zur
neuen bio leute ich habe heute meine
ganze familie mitunter stärken so
vorschlag und dabei max ist auf meiner
linken seite mein kleiner bruder auf der
rechten seite ist habe ja meine kleine
schwester hinter mir ist meine mutter
die bleibt heute wahrscheinlich erstmal
in der cover leute wie spielen heute ein
familien werden würde er sieht aber dass
vor uns noch keine wasser bestehen das
ganze funktioniert auf dem video das
ganze passiert so leute wie haben hinter
der kamera lara die freunde vermag sie
wird wer würde er fragen von euch von
der community vorlesen und dann wird
unsere mutter denjenigen tunken auf
denen das zutrifft wäre es am ersten
machen würde und ich würde sagen heute
wir fangen sofort an
erste frage wer würde er das letzte
pizzastück essen
ich konnte mich weitestgehend entspannt
ich war dass es mich nicht
[Gelächter]
leute das ist neu
das dass du wieder situation wenn ihr
wisst aber vom mutter steht hinter euch
die ihr euer ganzes leben lang klar ist
gegenseitig aber die hat ja auch
bisschen abgefragt und dann denke ich
werden gedruckt werden und ja ich frage
wer würde er eine imaginäre freundin
schlecht freund erfinden weil es ihnen
ihr heimlich ist noch single zu sein
[Musik]
sehr gut das lager der lega das sehr
unfair nur bei maxi bzw
wer keine beziehung keine sozialen
beziehungen die frage wird
ich hab das ganze nicht wirklich
durchdacht eigentlich sollte man nur für
schlechte sachen getunkt werden leute
oder na ja ich würde ich glaube aber
stand ich habe mir heute wieder gedacht
eigentlich müsste ich mal nach amerika
ziehen so kennt ihr das wenn ich auf der
couch steht in deutschland ich denke er
würde er einen siebentägigen
party-marathon überstehen
[Gelächter]
ich würde jetzt mal 22 uhr schlafen
macht mir so viel last auf jeden fall
noch einmal eine woche ist verrat und
dann erst abends um halb zehn am
flughafen auf mallorca an so nicht haben
wer würde er die seltsamsten essens
kombinationen feiern werde ich heute
auch noch heute morgen war er
tatsächlich selbst schockiert ich sage
es möglich am frühstückstisch und haben
ihr ein extrem sitzen sich meine zehen
check ist alles egal und auch spareribs
sind an sich geil
wir hatten halt von gestern was besseres
gibts heute dementsprechend habe ich mir
einfach sind schnecken mit boris rhein
gefahren wo ist das problem
wir müssen mal so kannst du magst aus
prinzip
[Gelächter]
die mutter beklagt
[Musik]
[Gelächter]
dann kommst du selbst ich habe mal kann
ich mal sagen ich habe irgendwann mal im
urlaub hatte ich mal so ein oder zwei
mal so ein bisschen geld das man das
problem geklaut weil ich eine
playstation haben wollte
wir wussten nicht ob man ja das ist
gereicht hätte für eine playlist nicht
aufgefallen so fit ist
wer würde er im knast landen
[Musik]
zu schnelles fahren wer würde er die
süßigkeiten oder das essen abwägen damit
es gerecht verteilte derweil die beiden
würden sich alles rein versagen es gibt
verschiedene levels wenn wir so sagen
mal werden so 100 gramm schokolade für
alle habe er würde alles auch essen will
man sagen sie hat ja wer bist du gerade
hey ich würde anfangen würde mir denken
nur so ein stück zu nehmen will dann 80
prozent der tafel auf essen aber sonst
üblich lassen magst du dir einfach
dritteln wer würde er heimlich mit dem
auto der eltern wäre würde er in der
wildnis überleben
da würde ich aber auch sagen ich glaube
es wäre es wäre echt nicht mehr so
vielleicht noch ein bisschen besser
darin irgendwie so feindliche angriffe
abzuwehren oder so ich würde mich sehr
mit den wildschweinen anfreunden könnten
aber deutlich angriffen würdest du denn
so sagen dass sexistische wäre wenn er
eine woche ohne dusche aus
[Musik]
richtig mich jeden morgen feldlager sag
ich nur noch um die frage wer es eher
würde er ein monat aufs handy verzichten
[Musik]
was würdest was würdest du machen wenn
du keine großen bruder hält das in
youtube machen und neues handy
finanzieren ich habe mein altes iphone
habe ich ja meine kleine schwester
gegeben konzert mir bis heute keinen
cent
aber morgen passiert wer würde er bei
mitten im leben mit rtl nachmittag
ich würde es machen
300 euro bekommen das schon ich weiß
habe ich so weit gehen würde leute ganz
ehrlich so also selbst bei atv mit zu
sein und dann nicht mehr entscheiden zu
können
das ja die online ist oder nicht wer
würde er sich die haare grün färben
ich habe ein kumpel von mir war darüber
geredet dass ich mir alle meine haare
abrasieren will und den beliebten und
dann so die er dem anderen etwas
anhängen was er getan hat
[Musik]
magst doch mag es ja schon so sehr gut
war auch gestern abend wir sind hier zu
suchen haben unsere keiner geschafft und
meine so tabea wieso ist der teppich
hier unten noch so sagen sie oh ja da
die und die was gekleckert nicht mehr so
ja es ist aber immer noch nicht trocken
machen ach so ja dann weiß nicht ich
habe gesagt ja okay dann sage ich dem
kissen das ist auch sich selbst
wer ist schon so eine geistreiche
chaoten muss man sagen also wissen und
es passiert öfters mal chaotisch lachen
in ihrem zimmer und wenn man sie dann
damit konfrontiert und sagt ja was hat
es damit auf sich dann war es irgendwie
immer jemand anderes ja eigentlich gar
nicht reden ich hab ja wir sind so die
theorie dass ich so genau genommen die
er zu spät
die frage ist nur wer meister ja ich
habe mich gerade noch so freundlich ist
und der gehört der der am allermeisten
zu spät kommt der ist gar nicht dass
unser vater soll das heißen würde er
etwas unter dem bett der anderen
verstecken damit man selbst keinen ärger
kriegt
[Gelächter]
ich hab's nicht mehr letzten zehn tag
wurde mit acht heller und anschließend
mit essen also 85 verschimmelte unter
dem bett leute vielen dank an alle die
mitgemacht haben maximal verlinkt haben
und ich lasse der kamera dank hatte ich
vermag mir hier leute die wir
vorschlagen das video hier oben könnte
meinen kanal abonnieren und dafür schon
bismarck